but a man who has never abused you be
part of the problem on why I'm part of
the problem you're American you're a
white woman you're part of the problem
how are you guys
why don't you stand on that what what
problem am I a part of
you think that being quiet and a woman
has benefited your life
do I think being white and a woman has
has it gone in your favor being a white
woman because I know statistically if I
was to go missing tonight on the way
home and you did they're going to be
looking for me more than you I know that
that's not fair but that is the way he
is right and and that that's what
baffles me is when we could talk about
race we can see it like that but like
when we can like I said to you earlier
like I'm English I know full well if I'm
out and people slow in English I ain't
got nothing to say what can I say it's
true